hello and welcome to this new science
show for in this video we're going to
talk about chocolates and whether it was
a good idea to have it for breakfast as
opposed to a different time of the day
so apparently many people my age don't
eat breakfast but for me breakfast is my
main meal of the day and I love
chocolates and I've had many chocolate
breakfasts in my life and well partly
because if I have it at nighttime I just
can't sleep so being the chocolate and
breakfast fanatic that I am I was
thrilled when I came across this paper
the other day which literally says
chocolate for breakfast prevents
circadian D synchrony and experimental
models of jet lag and shift work so in
this video let's break this paper down
and explore whether there's any truth
and any benefits to having chocolates at
breakfast so the benefits described in
this paper refer to improving circadian
D synchrony so firstly we kind of needs
to go through circadian rhythms just a
general overview so that you're on the
same page that I'm on
so the circadian rhythm our rhythms that
occur roughly about today and they're
just changes in the body regarding
behavior physiology metabolism and cell
activity and the reason that certain
processes happen at certain times of the
day is necessary to prepare organisms
for the daily challenges and requires a
well coordinated synchrony between the
day and night cycles I have other videos
on more detail regarding circadian
rhythms which are evidently very popular
so you should check this out if you want
to but in particular check out house
Acadian clock defects cause disease
because that's most relevant to this
video because what we know is that we
live by three clocks and so these three
different clocks are the Sun and the
changes between the light and dark
cycles the circadian clock I just
mentioned and also our social clock and
so it's often referred to as social
jetlag but also you got physical jetlag
and any courtship work and the thing is
there's a lot of evidence accumulating
they'll back as particularly chef
markers because of the D synchrony that
they have with their social core crew
got
in comparison to the circadian clock
they have a higher risk of developing
cancer so what does paper sort out to do
was to see whether chocolate and having
chocolate at breakfast can help prevent
these consequences from occurring before
white chocolate and wife eat this all
sounds a little bit random well just
hold out for a second basically food
intake is a potent synchronizer for the
circadian rhythms so like light and dark
cycles food intake can also play a role
in coordinating circadian rhythms for
some organs not all tissue types and
there's been many studies have shown the
importance of regulating food intake to
reduce the detrimental metabolic effects
of circadian disruption okay / still
white chocolate why not apples
well maybe the authors are also
chocolate fans like I am because they
have previously reported that scheduled
access to chocolate and trains brain
areas and false and motivation and in
the metabolic response to feeds and also
another study showed that scheduled
chocolates also in trains the circadian
system enhancing the amplitude of
neuronal activation in the SDN which is
the part of the brain that coordinates
the circadian rhythm so based on this
they hypothesized at the time eating of
a piece of chocolates kids prevent
circadian disruption so to test this
hypothesis the team decided to test this
on rats and to give them chocolate and
possibly my favorite parts of the study
is the fact that their chocolate of
choice was kinder maxi bars and now I
mean I love these with kids but I quite
like this tweet that said how could the
reviewers accepts that kinder maxi's are
qualified as chocolates because let's be
honest but they're not really that
chocolatey compiled like a bar of Dairy
Milk but anyway that's what they decided
to use so anyway the author's took these
rats and the first thing they did was
defies an experimental design to jet lag
these rats and then to either give the
rats chocolates when they would usually
have breakfast because rats you know
purpose all the time right or they gave
them at the new breakfast time which is
six hours in advance I am taking this
seriously but I just find it funny I
have an image of rats eating kinder bars
in my head anyway here are some of the
results that they got and what they
found was the rats that had chocolate at
the new breakfast time so a faster
adjustment to the jetlag and this was in
terms of that general activity and
temperature which are bathed
occasionally regulated so chocolate seem
to have a beneficial impact in terms of
acute disruption to the circadian rhythm
but what about shift workers who have a
chronic disruption of the circadian
rhythm so in a similar thing to jetlag
tests the authors devised a strategy to
have the rats exposed to shift work
under the similar chocolate test and
interestingly what they found was that
rats that received chocolate for
breakfast gained seventeen percent less
body weights than the control group and
24 percent less than the shift worker
rats so this reduces some of the severe
consequences that are seen in shift
workers such as metabolic dysfunction
and waking but what about the
non-working rats and us humans he deigns
under gay shift work well interestingly
they found that chocolate for dinner and
the rats that weren't working had a
greater increase in body weight by 16%
more than the controls whereas those I
had chocolate for breakfast attains a
lower body waves so if I eat chocolate
for breakfast I'm going to lose weight
well no you have to remember that the
rats only had five grams whereas you
know one of these whole kinder maxi
Bowser's 20 grams which let's be honest
is nothing in terms of the chocolate
treats and well going back to the point
why did they see this association
between chocolates and the circadian
rhythm well the author's wacken it might
have something to do with the increased
arousal and excitement induced by
chocolate arrival but with the study we
have to remember
there are limitations firstly they took
this in rats and as we know I'm not a
mouse or a rat
I don't secondly it skim the chocolate
really chocolate and when anyway my
favorite for this paper is that it's
very interesting but I don't think it's
fully convincing gap at least until we
see some human studies but it's also
really important point that timing is
really important in terms of treatments
as I said before and it's well Easter so
it's a chocolate special so as always
hope you've learned something and thanks
for listening